The Freshman out of the
box Off the Mark for
chro I mean what else can you say again
comes up with the loose ball
shod and they can sense it they can feel
it and now the sigh of
[Applause]
release as Las Vegas has turned into the
city of
upsets as now Colorado takes down the
defending champ for their Seas
[Applause]
opener unbelievable showing coach Payne
has to be so proud of her team not just
knocking down shots
but battled every single
possession
rebounded battled in the paint with a
with a a team that was way bigger and
stronger than you at different positions
this Colorado team is very special I
mean Grant Hill said at halftime I'll
see you at the final four this team
should set the final four as their
expectation
wow and I think everyone Across the
Nation wouldn't be shocked if you say it
after after seeing that performance as
you can see the conversation with Shan
and Haley van ly and a lot of love
between the two point
guards and the
celebration
continues what an unbelievable
performance for the Colorado buffalos
with their biggest win in program
history what better way to start the
NCAA season off with the upset of the
number one team in the
country